I feel like guys are getting plastic
surgeries [ __ ] do that well I feel like
you look up oh hold right hell yeah yeah
my mother keeps trying get your lids
down sir all Brides on a bad idea will
suck up a lot of people have the lids
none and apparently the scar is in the
eyebrow you can't see you can't see it
you don't understand you know I look
into I'm not gonna do it
the bags under my eyes you know they can
just shoot some stuff in there and gets
rid of this no that's not true I don't
think that I went through this because I
get really bad under eye bag too yeah
really bad it's just what you do I went
there's that but I went to this guy two
guys this guy dr. Lancer who's like a
really famous and he was like we can put
filler we can put filler in but the
problem is he called it a column a
filler we can put a column a filler in
but that's when you start looking puffy
getting that like a puff you already are
puffy your skin so you could fit well I
don't even see what you're talking about
I got rest last night but usually ride
bags and he said that I put those
patches on and I put him in the freezer
and I and then I put two coke cans on my
face every morning so much would go down
out too much work he said you're not
allowed to eat salt
I'd say [ __ ] off yeah so I I had yeah so
I started on this like no salt if I'm
shooting something like right now I
don't give a [ __ ] about this so I don't
do it nobody drove from Woodland Hills
drove from what they said we live yeah
I'm more neighbors we're neighbors now
we're neighbor yeah everybody's out
there yeah
Pawar the other master house with a
giant pink Hummer and I was like oh
there's your house it looks like a rap
video columns designed by Versace has a
big like T on the gate yeah yeah you may
live KITT we have to bring back MTV
Cribs I feel like you I agree be very
good at that
no they said that it would create a
column and you would just look puffy and
swollen so I didn't do it but I would be
careful I feel mom not do some people
feel like eyetality - now I can do this
stuff yeah but there's you know I would
just tighten it up being but that's
harder no that's not yo yo weed
some people in common that have done
that show in their ears just like start
biting everywhere so you have to they
say that because I was talking to this
guy I was like why does all plastic
surgery look so bad it was like it
doesn't good surgery you don't notice
that's right yeah so there's tons of
actresses Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt what
do you think they're do I don't think
they're doing really yeah I be sorry
Charlie bring a brand new shoes like
people do like you Tom Cruise whispers
of like and they put they do it in
places do you would imagine so when I
got my ear bitten off number I went to
this guy from this we haven't talked
about this no I'm the only person that
has a Lear ear than you no I don't think
so yeah look this one got chopped I have
the same thing my head you okay we don't
have the same thing you had your ear the
same thing no we don't mind bitten off
my whiskers was doubled mine was cut off
then did you get a cut off my mom
accidentally cut when she was got my
hair when I lift up my ear off oh wait I
thought that was from wrassling no wait
the whole thing
no just the top sheet cut the top off
anyways you're everything I hear about
her just a plus a plus B plus C plus
well I've been here someone bit up now
and dog bit my ear off and then we had
to sew it back on we had to get it sewn
back on kill him why are we talking
about this cotton a plastic surgery no
Oblast surgery yeah oh so the guy that
was doing it is the head of the facial
transplant team at UCLA and Cedars
arrived I got it done and he was like oh
should we put filler in here to fix it I
was like I don't really give a [ __ ] but
he was explaining that the good work is
not the place you think it would be so
when women get like facelifts they'll
put filler here in the temples and it
just shows everything up yeah just pulls
everything up and then the first sign of
aging is the cartilage on your nose
good pair disconnecting so you reattach
it so it stops looking so hook so you'll
have a dick no I got it I got a nose by
the way your dick look like it's got you
don't look like it's still straight with
a heavy vein
you know exactly what it's like think
back here you go this is for you yeah
why you laugh at my good memory of my
day
don't live the memory of my dong well
your nose I can say from experience your
nose like nothing like Brendan's Danny's
in both our dongs and Tom Cruise's face
the whole time he's had work done broke
cartilage on your nose that's why
everyone goes to Brazil they go to get
that surgery why Brazil though cheaper
and just a good question I don't know I
don't work out so well for Russia's mom
I wouldn't Lenny wait wait so now I
gotta get my that is actual if I get my
if I get my nose that reattached if I
get used in this time you would see the
bigger problem with your nose is that
yeah it's very different nose when I was
younger I don't know please stop cuz you
know what else you can do what's wrong
you get filler that's not what your nose
looks that way be look at my nose
right no it's worse they're not I'm not
I'm not about look very handsome
yeah you know well I saw a rapport
yesterday Michael yeah a meeting at Soho
House and I hear what da [ __ ] that's in
the middle
why are you going to Soho House the
better question that's where you get all
your energy my nose my nose there you
find out about who falls on liya
we go from Raya their main tenant I'm
Brian windows acident they're a long
time like Andrew Santino how Zeo do
what's this
I don't know probably the store but look
at my little cute nose in my little I
tell you Brian I feel like I can say
this but I've you're very handsome thank
you yeah you are
I feel like in some other universe we
would have dated I know you would have
like destroyed my 20s I would have did
some other you know I would have been
really nice to you yeah you can destroy
my 40s everyone on that yeah it's gonna
be an old man and I'll get my lads time
I show up looking everything how old is
that picture of me and count on the
[ __ ] that's mine you can never do
those awards now the guys only Awards on
Spike really that was so much fun
yeah hey is this how the show works now
you just look up yourselves no you guys
run it up that's from that's just 1/16
yeah like three years ago yeah yeah no
just walking the red carpet together
yeah times were different man exactly
three years ago Wow Wow I know a lot of
people getting necklace necklace hmm you
just pulled the neck it's just the neck
there's also do you know about the
string look that up I want that this is
what a lot of people this is what a lot
of people apparently do it's a string
that goes in from behind your ear under
your chin and then it pulls everything
back you don't apparently it's like a
dog you do it at lunch and you can go
home Brian get that bro I'm quitting it
dissolves I think I'm certain amount of
time what's it called the magic string
or something otoplasty ready ready to
Grandby I'll get I'll pay for it great
I'll pay for it
apparently threading is a big thing
here's the plan though why can't you
just get it done once and it's sticks
you always got like keep doing it like
girls who get their lips done they can't
see how to do it the thing that doesn't
dissolve what do you want them to put in
their [ __ ] concrete metal yeah and
how do you know they keep getting it
done what is this where are these
statistics coming from
oh I'm sorry fact check begins how do
you know how hurt
tox is alas sorry random statistic mean
what can't get your lips done once and
you're good for life
it's Botox Botox has a show I don't
think it's Botox Botox in the living
that freezes lips is a filler and filler
does not last for life you ask any girl
you've ever dated besides me
correct that's how I know I know
so they tell you yes why why wouldn't
they know I like to know what's going on
um I can't wait to get plastic surgery
this can be I'd say get your nut I think
that it's I my neck doesn't need doing
yet come on you would just pull it I
think wrinkles sir here's the problem
with guys wrinkles are sexy Yeah right
clothes are good yeah but you look good
you look as good as I've seen you thank
you yeah you look healthy
Jesus our ears are a little high I sleep
a lot there's nothing you can do about
that about yourself I do think though
that lift lip injection ever since the
lip injections everyone thinks my lips
are fake because I think everyone's are
fake now so you don't look like your
fake lips yeah well I can we've had them
for but you've had them for a hot second
yeah I mean all your lips in Greenup
sans yeah thank you but everyone thinks
my cheeks are fake too because now
people put Restylane is that what it's
about why am I looking at a perfect face
right I know there's something you can
put in your cheeks now to make them
higher yes so everyone thinks that I do
that well I forgot it's tricky for guys
she'd do it and it implants big surgery
it's again like this size calves calves
are grotesquely big yeah yes because
while calves and I think it's uh PEC
implants are number one for guys thank
you I didn't plant but I think is
getting the technology starting to get
there dude breast implants you could use
and they um got recalled I think so
I don't know what hey you did somebody
tried to extort you and then you
anyway but why did girls like you have
nice breasts
wait adjust way to just skim past that
you really like to go up to the
hard-hitting double well let's try to
store you anyway yeah but the way you're
told you are alright yeah no these are
amazing so I don't run again I don't
know I'm just not not dealing with it
you know I just power through it yeah I
just like white not go through it one
mana just write down little read it up
these Armitage yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]